what is your writing process like man
because you are such a prolific writer
you come up with these Concepts you come
up with these bars that are so [__]
crazy so for you is this off the top are
you cutting Melodies first are you in
your phone writing like what is your
writing process like when you're cutting
records
um I've been writing for so long and I
make so many records All Above like I
could do it all I got
wild ammo on my phone my computer
um in my book bag I got like five rap
books
um
sometimes I never wrote I just kept it
in my head and went and laid it yeah
people don't witnessed me do it all
different type of ways and because I'm
so active and try to stay on top of it
I'll be figuring that um
that's the best way to do it not just
one way like sometimes when I get the
time I like the right that's the best
way I feel like seeing actually what you
think about and writing it down is the
best process to me
but
um I wish a lot of these kids would
write more and not punch in because I
feel like when you write I feel like
there's something about that process
where you like the punching in [__] is
cool but I feel like
it's on the fly so you're really not
putting too much thought into each each
line like if it comes out cool it comes
out cool but I feel like when
motherfucker's right like who who was on
our Show recently they said they stopped
punching and they started writing
somebody like once I started writing
like my [__] just got better got sharper
because every line really I gotta write
it down like you know what I mean like
yeah this whole generation they'd just
be punching in man you've been through
so many of a couple words say it you
know they were like what was something
cool I could say here and then they go
to the next line you know I mean I was
gonna say this whole
um well you specifically man your career
your life you've been through so many
Peaks and valleys that we've got to
witness as fans what
um
has inspired you to
um just keep going man because you know
I feel like you've been through a lot
and a lot of the [__] you've been
through that we've got to see you go
through might break somebody or might
you know
throw a real fork in their career and it
feels like you're you're in your bag
right now it feels like you you're
really on top of your [__] I think the
reason why I started doing this I
started wanting a rat when I was super
young
before I had responsibilities I was
looking at it like a business I just
wanted to be the best right so that's
why I fell in love with it for bars for
lyrics and wanting to be the best and I
still got that passion to this day so a
lot of people be in it for business
reasons so when they find out how
sheisty this industry is how [__] up
the business is then it's like how can
you keep motivation if you was in it for
business and you find out how [__] up
the business is what's going to keep
what's going to keep you yeah what's
gonna keep you in it if you got in it
for the like look like the other rappers
or where the jury and you find out that
a lot of them [__] up a lot of the
jury fake or even the ones that's real
the Jewelers getting over on [__] and
you start finding out all the behind the
scenes details everything don't make you
had to drive like when you were kid and
uninformed but the reason why I wanted
to do it is still valid like I want to
be the best I like to impress people
with what I think about like
how I'm able to just come up with
thoughts write it down or say it and
impress people that's what I wanted to
be the best at so that's what motivate
me to keep going and no matter what I do
like no matter how much money I get no
matter what position I'm in or how my
life go I'ma still have the passion to
do that like wear this
um my career and I do it for a business
or it's just like a hobby something I do
for fun I'm gonna still always do it
because
it's rooted in passion yeah that's like
that's like Kevin Durant always says man
I just want a hoop like I'd be I would
be hooping if I wasn't getting paid like
it's my love you know what I'm saying
for sure
um
music wise what do you got on the way
you are you all right because I know
you're you're you got the battle [__]
going crazy you just had it did you just
battle or you were at the Battle this
weekend did you have a battle this
weekend no I just was hosting I'm
hosting a lot of these events um hosted
the rbe event a smack event just hosted
this event create for you that they put
together
so I missed the podcast I'm doing media
I'm hosting to get more attention on
battle rap to make it better for the
battle rappers and for myself when I do
finally get back in battle
but um I ain't set up on the actual
battle the name yet to tell you but
um I'm in negotiations with a lot of
people so hopefully I have like at least
two battles this year hopefully fire but
what about are you or like on the music
tip are you working on anything
oh yeah my new project I feel like is
the best project of my life like this
new music I got this new wave I'm on
it's like I'm happy with it and I can't
wait to drop it I'm just
um independent and doing everything from
the muscle and because I feel so good
about this project I just wanted to be
perfect so I got some little finishing
touches I got to put on it before I
release it but it's coming ASAP and it's
crazy I got the single already done we
gonna shoot the record of my um new
project today with Fred money out here
shout out to Fred money man yeah
it's um but um
I'm about to shoot another single real
soon grinding when we go back to Atlanta
but I think me living out of land and
being in that new environment is what
got me like still spitting bars and
lyrical but the bounces and the flows
and the the bag I'm in is just like
different than you would expect to hear
from me especially a dude that's been in
it as long as me so I can't wait what's
your relationship with Swiss like these
days
still the same man that's my brother
um we not connected to hang out like we
used to you know what I'm saying but
people grow still communicating still
Tech still work you still give me advice
and we still like family got a lot more
connections other than me and swiss like
me and his pop me and his uncles me and
a bunch of people that's connected with
Swiss like and I mean it's so many years
that I've been tied up that I can't
really separate my